The Avengers have one job: to protect people.
The actors that play the Avengers have an
even harder job, though: protecting the secrets
of the next big Marvel blockbuster.
And some of them are better at it than others.
So it's a good thing the fate of the world
doesn't depend on their silence, because otherwise
Earth would be doomed thanks to these Marvel
actors who revealed big spoilers about Avengers
4.
Sebastian Stan spills secrets
It may seem like every character in the MCU
appeared in Avengers: Infinity War, but according
to the Winter Soldier himself, Sebastian Stan,
the cast of the sequel will be even more stacked.
Stan told The Independent,
"There was one scene, I think, we had where
everybody was there.
It took them three months in planning this
scene to have everyone there.
You look around and you just saw everyone
from Samuel L. Jackson to Michael Douglas
to Michelle Pfeiffer.
Everybody was there."
Considering Stan, Jackson, Douglas, and Pfeiffer
were all turned to dust by Thanos in Avengers:
Infinity War and the Ant-Man and the Wasp
post-credits scene, this might be the biggest
spoiler of them all, as it implies they'll
all be brought back to life.
Hmm!
Zoe Saldana slips up
The official title of Avengers 4 has been
kept tightly under wraps, with Marvel Studios
head Kevin Feige suggesting that it's actually
a spoiler for Infinity War.
However, some fans thought they had gotten
the scoop when Zoe Saldana told a reporter,
"I think that the Guardians just shot their
part when it comes to Infinity War like the
first part, and we all have to go back for
Gauntlet later this year."
Guardians of the Galaxy director James Gunn
later said that Saldana misspoke, and that
the title isn't Infinity Gauntlet at all.
Whatever the case, Feige told IGN he regrets
making such a big deal about it to begin with.
"It's gotten entirely out of hand.
And now will have no chance to living up to
any expectations of what it's gonna be.
And it sort of backfired, if I'm honest with
you, because the notion was to not talk about
it so the focus was to be on [Infinity War]."
Drax deflates death
Almost all of the Guardians of the Galaxy
were lost at the end of Avengers: Infinity
War.
But will they stay dead?
Former Guardians director James Gunn had said
he planned to conclude the team's storyline
in Guardians of the Galaxy Volume 3; he has
since been fired, but it still seems reasonable
to assume that a lot of them will make their
way back from the dead in the fourth film.
Star Dave Bautista seemingly confirmed that
his Drax the Destroyer will be one of those
people, saying in an interview with Collider,
"[After Avengers: Infinity War] I got a lot
of texts saying, 'I can't believe you're dead,
your character is dead.'
They were really like heartbroken and I was
like, 'I'm gonna be in [Avengers] 4.
I'm gonna be in Guardians 3.'
I don't know how they're bringing me back,
yeah, but somehow I'm going to make it because,
as far as I know, I am going to be in Guardians
3, so I have to be back."
This was also seemingly confirmed by Chris
Pratt, who said in an instagram post that
he "Can’t wait to start shooting Guardians
Volume 3" with co-star Pom Klementieff.
Considering both of their characters, Star-Lord
and Mantis, also bit the dust alongside Drax
in Avengers: Infinity War, it certainly seems
some sort of mass resurrection is in store
for the Guardians of the Galaxy.
Thanos snaps back
Josh Brolin's Thanos did away with most of
the MCU's heroes in Infinity War, but the
post-credits scene for the film hinted that
there was still hope for the universe in the
form of Brie Larson's Captain Marvel, who
will be introduced in her own 1990s-set standalone
film before joining the rest of the gang for
Avengers 4.
Although we've known for a while that Captain
Marvel will appear, Brolin appeared to drop
at least a bit of a spoiler when he said that
he shared a scene with Larson, hinting that
Thanos will have a head to head confrontation
with her Carol Danvers.
Brolin also revealed that Black Widow, War
Machine, Thor, Captain America, and Iron Man
were present, which is notable since those
characters were all among the few survivors
at the end of Infinity War.
Stark Jr.?
Gwyneth Paltrow's appearance in Infinity War
hinted at a happy future for Tony Stark and
Pepper Potts, with Tony suggesting that the
pair could soon start a family.
Paltrow, though, revealed even more in an
interview with the Official Avengers: Infinity
War magazine, suggesting that that dream will
actually come to fruition in Avengers 4, saying,
"Pepper and Tony have had a real long journey
together.
She obviously starts as his dutiful assistant,
and then the relationship evolves, and now
this decade later they're married, and they
have a child.
Their relationship has evolved in all of the
ways that great romances evolve."
Can't keep a good Mackie down
Falcon didn't make it through the end of Infinity
War, but Anthony Mackie may have inadvertently
revealed that he'll return from the great
beyond.
In December, 2017, the star tweeted a photo
of himself from the set of Avengers 4, saying,
"Sometimes you have to sit back and marvel
at where you are."
And sometimes you have to just celebrate being
alive… again.
Heimdalls and Heimdon'ts
Although a lot of characters seem to be making
their way back for Avengers 4, at least one
apparently won't be.
Idris Elba, whose character Heimdall was killed
at the start of Avengers 4, revealed on his
Twitter account that he would not be coming
back, writing "#SpoilerAlert Gonna miss my
guy."
Hey.
At least he put a spoiler tag on it!